welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and godzilla vs kong learns a
lesson from thor vs thanos to always go
for the head
and slurp out the juices
i freaking love this movie and i'm gonna
break it down scene by scene for all the
interesting details that you might have
missed
spoiler warning let's go okay the film
opens on skull island actually shot the
blazing
sun similar to the opening shot of
2017's kong skull island we see leaf
wings from that film fly past but of
course this is not the real sun it's
just a projection of it inside kong's
artificial habitat
his grouchy glare is likely partly due
to him knowing this sunlight is not
real setting up the ending for such a
nice closure
where all he needs is the air that he
breathes now to make kong an adequate
match with godzilla in this movie kong
has grown since we last saw him in the
year 1973 which is actually about 50
years before this movie is set
and back then he was described as still
an adolescent
kong is the last of his kind but he's
still growing we get this great morning
montage set to bobby vinton's over the
mountains across the sea and the girl
waiting for him
is gia deaf actress kaylee hoddle she's
the last living member of the ewe tribe
who we saw on conscious island that
perennial storm that once orbited skull
island that 2017 film
now covers it and wiped out the tribe
leaving gia
under kong's protection and her deafness
uniquely makes her unfearful of his
roars which intimidates everyone else
now this habitat is labeled monarch
outpost
236 meaning in the five years since
godzilla king of the monsters these
monarch outposts have increased from the
like double digits to
the hundreds actually fun little detail
kong's tree trunk spear breached
sector 7g which simpsons fans know this
that's the sector of the nuclear power
plant where homer simpson works in but
before we continue thank you to our
sponsor rage shadow legends the game
that has taken over the mobile gaming
world they've got 500 different
champions with unique skills and endless
ways to equip and upgrade them so that
everyone can raid their way
use the links below to download raid
yourself on your mobile phone or your pc
i've been playing raid for a while now
and there are a few champions i really
like using
cold heart is this dark elf archer who
has this amazing heart seeker ability
that lets her do tons of damage to the
bosses and occult
brawler is this epic champion who places
a ton of poisons on enemies he's super
useful against the clan boss and that's
on top of all the other weirdos that you
can find in the index like look at this
guy
rudolph you know with his with his crazy
antlers but he's got like a jack human
body and a little candy cane
sword it's making me feel a lot of
things i didn't think i'd feel but he's
got his bright red nose
and let him play the reindeer game i
just really like that this game is
constantly growing and they're always
adding
in new elements like just when i think
it got a handle on the campaign or pvp
arena they add in something new like
doom tower
and ray just had their two-year
anniversary with a load of anniversary
events and tournaments going on right
now so jump in to catch some of those
special events and get your hands on
some free gifts and rewards with all the
events tournaments and free gifts
available it's never been easier to get
started raid also just released the
first batch of the badass shadowkin
faction
a brand new asian inspired faction with
some amazing looking champions to get so
if you want to get a head start in raid
all you have to do is hit that link in
the description or scan the qr code and
you'll get a free epic champion
who is amazing for the doom tower 100
000 silver 50 gems and three ancient
shards so that you can summon more
awesome champions all of this treasure
will be waiting for you right up here
and it is that easy just click the link
in the description and i will see you in
the game now these opening credits are
full of visual details and easter eggs
like every single title credit comes
with redacted text around it that
contains a comment about the
accompanying name
within the context of the movie like
alexander skarsgard
needs to prove the existence of hollow
earth to salvage his tarnish reputation
countless explorers have attempted to
prove the connection i used a gonzalez
and many have perished teasing her
character's grim
fate later in this movie the monster
sounds are compared to music by tom
hulkenberg working from skeletal remains
costume designer and foley
fleshed out the renderings of monster's
appearance now beneath all these titles
ancient art shows a battle between
past ancestors of these two kaiju the
past kong wielding a weapon
a clue for the advantage that his
descendant will use the art for the book
by dr nathan lind hollow earth gravity
paradox and our new frontier this hollow
earth theory was actually first brought
up in the series by houston brooks in
conscious island
the bedrock is practically all out it's
called the hollow earth theory
randa hired me because i wrote a paper
substantiating what most people think is
a crackpot idea
and this was later confirmed in this
fictional universe in godzilla king of
the monsters by bradley whitfield's
character
i knew it man the vortex was a tunnel
into the hollow earth and all this
imagery calls back these past films bill
randa's
1973 expedition of skull island we see
godzilla killing the muto
in the 2014 film with that kiss of death
the paperwork describes it as
internal combustion another card shows
godzilla's stats
393 feet tall 164
000 tons i guess he was formerly 99 000
tons and walks 18 miles per hour now by
comparison later we see
kong stats listing him as 104 feet tall
and 158 tons that's got to be a misprint
godzilla is not
a thousand times heavier than kong maybe
these were his metrics in the 70s or
maybe they just forgot to add the ooo
there but more importantly his profile
describes him as highly adaptive and
resourceful
uses tools like an axe immensely
powerful tough and resilient great
recuperative powers susceptible to
flammable attacks and then enemies
giant squid skull crawlers and titan he
fought the squid and the skullcrawlers
in that 2017 film now he's gonna fight
the titan now that alpha skull crawler
actually shows up here
titanos cranium reptant the nomenclature
uses marlo's skullcrawler nickname
cranium for skull reptant for the latin
root of reptile which means to creep or
to crawl
skullcrawler and its cause of death is
listed as disembowelment and then of
course
ghidorah the devil with three heads from
godzilla king of the monsters in 2019
cause of death atomic incineration from
the way godzilla finished this off in
boston
remember that movie's post-credits scene
showed alan jonah recovering a
previously severed ghidorah head from
the one that was ripped off in the coast
of mexico which they use in this movie
to construct the brain of mecca godzilla
and all these credits culminate with
a bracket final two setting up this
brawl between these two alphas as
inevitable
apex engineer bernie hayes hosts a
conspiracy theory podcast he passes this
video hosted by new apex ceo walter
simmons
the human mind artificial intelligence
that guy's wearing similar neural
interface headgear that ren serizawa
uses to link with mechagodzilla
and this video ends with these words
i guess it was intended to mean the
titans won't make us extinct we're not
going anywhere but it does have this
creepy undertone of
you're trapped in this hell with us
you're not going anywhere and then
godzilla swims up
giving us our first real blast of that
classic toho godzilla theme
and as they evacuated apex cto renzo was
zawa stares godzilla down now he is the
son of ishiro serizawa let them fight
you remember him he died in the last
film to bring godzilla back
so this moment shows how bringing down
godzilla is personal for this guy now
bernie finds this big robot eyeball
this is going to be the eye of
mechagodzilla and it already gives us
this beastly growl
and this three chime tone
showing how this is based on the dna of
a beast of a kaiju a titan ghidorah
and it is setting up that three-tone
roar of mechagodzilla in hong kong
billy bobby brown returns as madison
russell daughter to kyle chandler mark
russell
still recovering from the death of emma
russell in the past film she helped apex
use orca sonar tech to summon titans and
to try to control them
emma actually shows up in an article
among madison's research beside this
publication this is the aromantic
deception
rudolph steiner's 1985 lecture is about
the sign of the times of lucifer's
coming back bernie's past podcast
episodes are similarly conspiracy
inspired
godzilla's not the enemy it's called
collateral damage people godzilla's
sudden attack nobody puts godzilla in
the corner
mothra's pregnancy theory so who's the
baby daddy
maybe that's a nod that mothra egg that
was teased in the king of the monsters
in credit montage
avoiding apex trackers the ins and outs
of fighting big brother and godzilla
missing
just because we can't see him doesn't
mean he can't see us madison and josh
find
bernie in chinatown this restaurant has
neon lights of an
eye like the mechagodzilla eye that
bernie's obsessed with and behind
madison is another light that kind of
looks like the legendary logo the studio
that made this movie and then bernie
says
tapper no tap no tap they put fluoride
in it learn it from the nazis
theory is a makeshift docile easy to
manipulate oh yes water fluoridation now
they do
put fluoride in the water but it's for
dental health though that doesn't stop
the belief among a lot of folks that
there's some sinister agenda behind it
especially in the real world when people
have said they have put stuff in the
water the water isn't safe to drink
that has totally been proven true in
places like plant michigan actually
jordan peel used this same fluoride
example in 2019's us
where the daughter was talking about in
the back seat on the drive up
foreshadowing in that fictional world it
wasn't that crazy to believe that there
are
underground tunnels linking everything
as there are in this godzilla world now
some into saraswat recruit nathan lind
from denham
university which could be named after
carl denham the film producer from the
1933 king kong who went to skull island
and in peter jackson's 2005 remake they
used magnetic scans to prove lin's
hollow earth theory was accurate
the whole time and give them a path to
the planet's core
where there's a power source that the
titans use to nurture their growth they
want to use this power
source to kill godzilla and simmons
introduces how they're going to get
there the heave
hollow earth aerial vehicle which is
similar to the super x aerial vehicles
from the 80s films and they ship kong
from skull island to antarctica hoping
that he will be able to lead them to
this hollow earth on the ship a screen
shows how they're sedating him but also
you get a shot of the release lever that
nathan will later need to pull when
they're underwater to free kong and
uncapsize this boat walt's daughter maya
simmons brags about these heaves
the anti-gravity engines alone produced
enough charge to light up vegas for a
week
to tighten up how lynn knows to use the
heave as a giant defibrillator to jolt
kong back to life in hong kong we
learned that gia has taught kong's sign
language and we get this great finger to
finger shot
that ironically evokes michelangelo's
creation of adam with the godly figure
now an ape and the man a young girl
godzilla catches up with kong in the
tasman sea notice how the artillery fire
is accompanied by these choir voices
hauling back that amazing teaser for the
2014 film which had a
similar choir sound to it
then we get this great pov shot from
godzilla's dorsal plate
identifying this monster by only its fin
kind of like the shark and jaws actually
we get a jaws reference here when the
anchor chain gets tethered to godzilla
and he tows this cruiser
quietly slipping it underneath the water
similar to how the shark tows the
barrels and then just kind of
drags them under creepily and by the way
these dorsal plates were redesigned in
2019 from their 2014 looks so that they
would look more curved and jagged like
the classic 1954 toho design and the two
titans face-off on the aircraft carrier
there's lots of great human point of
view shots to give us a sense of scale
from the fighter pilot in the cockpit as
kong throws it to
placing the camera on the flight deck as
godzilla crawls on
tilting upward as ocean spray drops down
onto the lens
but then right as the punch comes in
they cut too wide because think about it
a punch has the most dramatic impact
from afar kind of like you're watching
boxers in a ring so just in a matter of
seconds director adam wingard makes us
feel two things
awe of the titans immense size but then
also blood thirst just to see them beat
the out of each other then when
godzilla claws back and knocks kong into
the water
as that ape dips into the waves the
camera from our point of view
goes down into the water as well it
links us with that fall
so just with great composition this
creative team elevates what would
otherwise be
a simple big monster fight and it's
something that's really beautiful and
really fun to watch
godzilla blasts his atomic breath
skyward wrecking the carrier and we cut
super wide like a mile away showing how
high this blast goes into the
stratosphere
and this scale helps us later on in the
final act when godzilla blasts long
range down below the hollow earth we're
like
yeah we know that he could blast that
far so the airlift kong to antarctica
with a fleet of helicopters the director
actually said this is an homage to the
1962 king kong vs godzilla when kong is
airlifted via hot air balloon
they actually also use helicopters to
airlift kong to the north pole
in 1967's king kong escapes then from
there they descend into the hollow earth
core
this is a super trippy landscape with
two mirrored terrains and abnormal
gravity
as they adjust to the new gravity and
the heave the camera goes inverted for a
second and then flips right side up kind
of adjusting us as well
another fun shot orients us with like
this river and this waterfall looks all
great but then wait hold on we tilt up
to reveal we're actually looking down
from the opposite surface from kong and
the others here they're attacked by the
nozuki aka the warbats
kong fights them gets smothered by its
wings so
later when he gets free the first thing
he does is fold up this wing
and then it ends by him ripping off the
head and enjoying the spoils
so when kong crosses the gravitational
plane the peak on the other side is
carved to look like a giant hand
even bigger than he is kind of like the
hand of god reaching out
giving kong his own creation of adam
moment as he reconnects with his
ancestors
bernie madison and josh discover
mechagodzilla being controlled by the
mind of ransarizawa
in the ghidorah skull using that neural
psionic link that the ghedora would use
to link its three heads
and i love how the music for
mechagodzilla is kind of the synthy
electronic remix of the main godzilla
theme
[Music]
so the skull crawler eggs they found are
actually skull crawlers that are used to
test mechagodzilla's strength notice
this skull crawler has super bright
colors
showing what skull crawlers would look
like if they never burrowed beneath
skull island and had to adapt to that
darkness
now in the temple kong finds his axe and
look at this blade this is made
out of a dorsal plate of a past godzilla
making this both an offensive weapon
and a shield for an attack that kong
could not protect against before
and a proud historical relic for the
kong lineage saying we've beaten your
kind before we can do it again
but surrounding the kong throne is a
glowing imprint of a past godzilla
reptilian shape
almost like a cautionary warning to the
kong don't get too cozy on that throne
cause your rival is
always snaking around you now maya gets
greedy tries to mine some of that hollow
earth irradiated mineral for fuel
and in this ensuing scramble they in a
weird way get saved by godzilla's
downward atomic breath
in this way godzilla gives him a kind of
shortcut both so that kong can come
fight him and for the humans it becomes
their escape hatch oh and uh maya
doesn't make it
now this hong kong battle is glorious to
watch
using the neon lights of the nearby
buildings causes the skin and the fur of
these two titans to reflect the lights
illuminating them vibrantly and allowing
us kind of a point of reference to know
where they always are in this fight now
early in this fight godzilla again just
tries to charge up the atomic breath it
worked last time why would it work this
time but kong's ahead of him he senses
it
grabs that jaw and then forces it closed
like putting his hand over a fire hose
kong gets so fed up with it he just
takes the handle of his axe and
stuffs it down godzilla's throat this is
actually a callback to the 60's king
kong vs godzilla movie when kong rips a
tree
out of the ground and kind of plunges it
into godzilla's throat but the further
kong gets away from godzilla the more he
gives godzilla the upper hand because
godzilla's got a lot of range attacks
he's got the atomic breath he uses his
tail whips he actually takes the axe and
flings it back
at him so in order to try to get an
advantage hong has to apply the one
thing he has over godzilla opposable
thumbs he uses tools here he rips off
the disc shaped floor of the building
uses it as a shield and he does that so
he can get back his axe and he uses that
blade's own supercharged
radiation in the coolest way
but the knight ultimately goes to
godzilla who dislocates kong's shoulder
and pins him
let kong's still pissed i love that they
both have these matching strings of
drool between their jaws and during all
this mechagodzilla goes online and as
always is the case unpairs with its
human captors and goes rogue
and attacks godzilla rattling around
nearby boardroom chairs i love that shot
lind uses the heave to heave kong back
to life a bit similar to the 1962 king
congress godzilla where a bolt of
lightning resuscitates kong and once
kong is back on his feet he pops his
shoulder back in
just like riggs does and lead the weapon
too
now as in the mid 70s films godzilla vs
mechagodzilla and terror of
mechagodzilla mechagodzilla's blast
overpowers godzilla's atomic breath but
the battle still ends with this robot's
head getting torn off except here kong
gets to do the honor but only because he
has the weapon made
from a piece of godzilla's ancestors and
kind of like captain america dropping
the shield that does not belong to him
kong drops that godzilla dorsal blade
axe out of respect to his rival but they
still
hate each other i love it and they part
ways and we get the sudden cut to
silence as the tail slips beneath
the waves
[Music]
this is just like gareth edward's
amazing closing shot of the 2014 film
and the final shot gives kong the true
home he sought all he needs is the air
that he breathes
air that he has to share though because
while he is now ruler over this hollow
earth domain his
rival rules the surface earth above two
inseparable kings two
inseparable kingdoms you can support
this channel by checking out one of our
many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
here on youtube for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you